here's what hasn't changed in Saudi
Arabia women still can't drive cinemas
concerts Valentine's Day all our Lord
and Saudis are still pretty attached to
crude oil more accurately the life they
lead because of it this is what has
changed oil revenues have collapsed with
global prices and the country can no
longer afford generous handouts for its
citizens Saudi Arabia's coffers are
draining fast and now it's rulers are
scrambling to kick the country's
hydrocarbon habit all while keeping
their people on side so here's the
situation in 2015 King Salman assumed
the throne in the deeply conservative
Muslim nation his son Prince Mohammed
quickly built up enough power for
Western diplomats in Riyadh to dub him
mr. everything with oil the country's
finances and just about everything else
under his control the Prince launched a
plan to transform the Arab world's
largest economy and weaned off the
proceeds of crew this is how sell up to
five percent of Saudi Aramco the
country's national oil producer in what
could be the world's largest IPO sink
the proceeds into a sovereign wealth
fund that could eventually control more
than two trillion dollars that's big
enough to buy the four largest public
companies in the US and completely
revolutionize Saudi Arabia's employment
and social system cutting subsidies for
basic like electricity winding back the
bounteous grants that have helped keep
citizens compliant and getting more
Saudis to work for a living even women
so here's the argument Saudi Arabia's
been trying to diversify away from oil
for years but it hasn't been
particularly effective this ten billion
dollar financial district in Riyadh
filled with gleaming buildings sky
bridges and a monorail sits largely
unleased the economy is still powered by
foreign workers who make up 80 percent
of the private work force efforts to get
more Saudis into work have been met with
and rulers are running out of time even
with the world's biggest petroleum
fields and half a trillion dollars in
foreign reserves the good times are over
and there's a demographic tidal wave
approaching nearly half of Saudi
Arabia's 21 million citizens are under
25 and they make up a third of all
unemployed in the past any potential
challenge to the system was sated by a
cash veloute social contract the Prince
Mohammed has signaled he's willing to
tear up the reforms could also put him
at odds with ultra-conservative Wahhabi
clerics who still wield great power
Saudis are confronting a future cheaper
oil in a country where oil is everything